[Lolo] Best friends' trip.
This is going to be iconic.
♪ Do it like that ♪
(upbeat music)
[Audrey] You do understand this
is a work trip for me?
- Audrey, I got you.
Look at me.
- You're thinking about a dick.
- Damn it, you're right.
♪ Look at me, look at me, look
at me now ♪
[Kat] I love a grand adventure.
- I heard that if you
keep up with
Chinese businessmen,
they respect you more.
(Audrey vomiting)
(crowd gasping)
♪ Listen up, listen up,
listen up ♪
[Jess] Fuck!
- Oh my God, you're a
drug dealer?!
- You gonna plug or you
gonna play?
- Is that a condom?
- You look like you've had
a lot of things
in your asshole.
- Not a lot of things,
just one thing,
but maybe different
varieties of that one thing.
(Kat grunting)
♪ Look at me, look at me,
look at me go ♪
- Stick your hand up
there like a claw machine
trying to get the stuffed bear.
- Okay.
- Get that bear.
- I'm getting the bear.
- Ah! Ah!
♪ So powerful ♪
♪ What ♪
[Chao] If you do not know
where you come from,
how do you know who you are?
- I'm just a garbage American
who only speaks English.
And a little Gollum.
"My precious.
Little filthy Hobbitses."
Do you guys have that here?
[Kenny] Yeah, we have--
It's all over the world.
♪ Y'all calling me crazy ♪
- Let's just be adults.
- Are you horny?
(loud banging)
♪ Then I ball like Spalding ♪
Sex isn't shameful.
It's beautiful.
Like the noises.
(hands slapping)
- Ah.
- Ooh. Ooh.
(Lolo slurping)
(both slurping)
(loud gulping)
(exaggerated gasping)
♪ I'm goin' crazy, yeah ♪
[Todd] May I?
(upbeat music)
(all screaming)
[Deadeye] Look at me!
(upbeat music)
[Xing Xing] Show them.
♪ There's some whores
in this house ♪
in this-- ♪
♪ Crazy, got 'em goin' crazy ♪
♪ Huh, huh ♪
- I'm not racist.
- You don't like boba
and you never fucked
an Asian guy.
- Damn, still?
- When I masturbate
I sometimes fantasize
about Splinter.
He's Asian.
- He's a rat.
- He's a good father!
♪ Crazy, go crazy ♪